عموما تختلف التوجهات الاستراتيجيه لدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي تجاه العلاقه مع وهنا قد
تكون القراءه واحده لكن المعالجه مختلفه
معالجه فرنسا للقضيه تقوم على التقارب مع
الصين للمبدا حافظ على اصدقائك قريبين
ولكن حافظ على اعدائك اقرب بينما المعالجه
الالمانيه تقوم على البعد عن الصين خاصه
بعد التجربه مع روسيا والتي ارهقت
الاقتصاد الاوروبي عموما والالماني على
وجه التحديد
[موسيقى]
فيما يتعلق بالعلاقات الصينيه الفرنسيه
فهي جيده اقتصاديا ممنعكس على العلاقات
السياسيه فالصين ثالث اكبر شريك اقتصادي
لفرنسا بعد كل من الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه وفي هذا
المجال تسعى فرنسا لتحقيق المزيد من
الاستقلال السياسي والاقتصادي عن السياسه
وهي بالتاكيد لا ترغب بالخروج عن الاجماع
السياسي الغربي لكنها في ذات الوقت لا
ترغب بان تكون تابعه تبعيه مطلقه كما انها
ترى مستقبلها الاقتصادي مع الصين وهو ما
يفسر الزيارات الرسميه الفرنسيه المتكر
ره
اما فيما يتعلق بالموقف الالماني طبعا هو
موقف سلبي نسبيا تجاه الصين فهو في جذور
خلاف سياسي واستراتيجي لكن يتم تسويقه على
انه خلاف لقصه من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه لا
ترغب المانيا بتكرار ذات الشمال والذي حدث
مع روسيا بعد قطع الغاز الروسي المانيا
تعتقد انه من الخطا الاعتماد الكبير على
مختلفه استراتيجيا ففي حال تصاعد التوتر
مع الصين قد تكون الاخيره بقطع العلاقات
الاقتصاديه مع اوروبا عموما ومع المانيا
على وجه التحديد وهو ما يعد خطرا
استراتيجيا اضافه الى ذلك فان الدعم
السياسي الالماني يثير حافظه ويدفع
العلاقات السياسيه والاقتصاديه بين
البلدين بمزيد من
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
التوتر
[موسيقى]
قياسات الاوروبيه تجاه الصين تتفق في بعض
المواضع وتختلف
الاتحاد الاوروبي بشكل عام يرغب بالحفاظ
على علاقات سياسيه متوازنه واقل تشدد
الطبع من السياسات الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
السبب هذا الموقف الاوروبي هو الرغبه في
دعم اي جهود صينيه لانهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا اضافه لكون الصين اليوم اصبحت
قطب اقتصادي عالمي وفي ظل الضغوط
الاقتصاديه المتصاعده على اوروبا تبدو
الصين منقدا اقتصاديا لها هذا في الاطار
العام اما فيما يتعلق بتفاصيل موقف الدول
الاوروبيه فلكل منها موقف مغاير فرنسا
مثلا من اكثر المهتمين بتطوير العلاقات مع
الصين سياسيا واقتصاديا في حين ان المانيا
لها نهج اكثر تشدد خاصه في الشق الاقتصادي